we have presented the complete solution
to the linear list mean squares
estimation problem when we want to
estimate a certain unknown random
variable on the basis of a different
random variable X that we get to observe
but what if we have multiple
observations what would be the analogous
formulation of the problem here is the
idea once more we restrict ourselves to
estimators that are linear functions of
the data linear functions of the
observations that we have and then we
pose the problem on finding the best
choices of these coefficients a 1 up to
a n and B what does it mean to find the
best choices it means that if we fix
certain choices we obtain an estimator
we look at the difference between the
estimator and that quantity were trying
to estimate take the square and then
take the expectation so once more we're
looking at the mean squared error of our
estimator and we try to make it as small
as possible so this is a well-defined
optimization problem we have a quantity
which is a function of certain
parameters and we wish to find the
choices for those parameters or those
coefficients that will make this
quantity as small as possible one first
comment is similar to the case where we
had a single measurement is the
following
if it turns out the conditional
expectation of theta given all the data
that we have is linear in X if it is of
this form then what happens we know that
this is the best possible estimator if
it is also linear then it is the best
estimator within the class of linear
estimators as well and therefore the
linear least mean squares estimator is
the same as the general least mean
squares estimator so if for some
problems it turns out that this is
linear then we automatically also have
the optimal linear
estimator and this is going to be the
case once more for certain normal
problems with a linear structure of the
type that we have studied earlier now
let us look into what it takes to carry
out this optimization if we had a single
observation then we have seen a closed
form formula a fairly simple formula
that tells us what the coefficients
should be for the more general case
formulas would not be as simple but we
can make the following observations if
you take this expression and expand it
it's going to have a bunch of terms for
example it's going to have a term of the
form a1 squared times the expected value
of x1 squared it's going to have a term
such as twice a1 a2 times the expected
value of x1 x2 and then there's going to
be many more terms
some of them will also involve products
of theta with this so we might see that
we have a term of the form a1 expected
value of x1 theta and then there's going
to be many many more terms what's the
important thing to notice that this
expression as a function of the
coefficient involves terms either of
this kind or of this kind or of that
kind first-order or second-order terms
to minimize this expression we're going
to take the derivative of this and set
it equal to 0
when you take the derivative of a
function that involves only quadratic
and linear terms you get something
that's linear in the coefficients the
conclusion out of all this discussion is
that when you actually go and carry out
this minimization by setting the
riveters to zero what you will end up
doing is
solving a system of linear equations in
the coefficients that you are trying to
determine and why is this interesting
well it is because if you actually want
to carry out this minimization all you
need to do is to solve a linear system
which is easily done on a computer the
next observation is that this expression
only involves expectations of various
terms that are second-order in the
random variables involved so it involves
the expected value of x1 squared it
involves this term which has something
to do with the covariance of X 1 and X 2
this term that has something to do with
the covariance of X 1 with theta but
these are all the only terms out of the
distribution of the XS and the Thetas
that will matter so similar to the case
where we had a single observation in
order to solve this problem we do not
need to know the complete distribution
of the x's and of theta it is enough to
know all the means variances and
covariances of the random variables that
are involved and once more this makes
this approach to estimation a practical
one because we do not need to model in
complete detail the distribution of the
different random variables finally if we
do not have just one unknown random
variable but we have multiple random
variables that we want to estimate what
should we do
well this is pretty simple you just
apply this estimation methodology to
each one of the unknown random variables
separately to conclude this linear
estimation methodology applies also to
the case where you have multiple
observations you need to solve a certain
computational problem in order to find
the structure of the best linear
estimator but it is not a very difficult
computational problem because all that
it involves is to minimize a quadratic
function of the coefficients that you're
trying to determine and this leads us to
having to solve a system of linear
equations for all these reasons linear
estimation or estimation using linear
estimators is quite practical